mais d'abord après le verre de trop la
gueule de bois jours de liesse hier soir
à tours avec cette place plumes noires
de monde vous avez pu voir les images
sur notre antenne
sauf que beaucoup lever le coude en
oubliant les gestes barrières et la
jauge ce qui n'a pas échappé à la
préfète qui restreint la consommation
d'alcool hélène chapelet 19 heures hier
soir place plumereau à tours pour la
réouverture des bars et restaurants les
clients étaient au rendez vous
enthousiaste après plus de sept mois
sans avoir pu s'asseoir en terrasse
mais l'euphorie a fait oublier les
recommandations d'usagé
la jauge de 6 personnes maximum par
table n'a pas toujours été respectée ni
l'interdiction de consommer de boue on
est contente tout ça mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya énormément de monde et c'est
très compliqué à gérer
vous devez faire la police un petit peu
un petit peu
on a un peu oui il faut le dire tu peux
dépasser je pense qu'on va s'organiser
autrement les jeux pour les jours qui
viennent
pod les gens cnp quatre peut-être un
petit peu mieux une situation qui n'a
pas échappé aux autorités compétentes la
préfecture d'indre et loire vient de
prendre un nouvel arrêté pour mieux
encadrer la consommation d'alcool sur la
voie publique
il sera à partir d'aujourd'hui interdit
de consommer de l'alcool en dehors des
terrasses qui sont gérés par les
responsables des établissements les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs on leur
fait confiance pour appliquer avec
efficacité les mesures de distanciation
mais il n'est plus possible de consommer
sur la voie publique autour de la place
plumereau et puis par ailleurs la vente
à emporter sur la voie publique la vente
au verre d'alcool ou de boissons est
interdite sur l'ensemble du département
des contrôles de police vont être
renforcés pour éviter les abus
chaque contrevenant s'expose à 135 euros
d'amande